Superman Superman does whatever catonian
and spins weddings nice mix of this
checks in twice look out here comes
Superman
look out here comes a Super Bee
dude Superman does not spin web if
you're gonna steal the spider-man song
least don't steal some of the lyrics by
accident - then what does that song have
to do with the movie after all it's not
even about Manistee and say it was about
the movie they just wrote a song about
Superman
well bye for fighting did well fine for
fighting is a hugely successful rock
band and you or not and also their
hockey fans which makes them cool I'm a
hockey fan dude you're a predators fan
but not hockey you know I know about a
half a million redneck so they're gonna
want to kick your ass after that Cup
right right after they get done kicking
your ass for calling the rednecks you
knew probably has a redneck Superman
what think about it he spends all this
time outdoors means flying so he eats
even closer to the Sun than we are that
his neck gets sunburned like a mother
dude
I mean he's Superman bullets bounce off
his chest I don't think that UV rays are
gonna hurt him come on
well someone obviously hasn't seen Man
of Steel I saw it with you what I
thought that was the other you well he
was there too well anyway I thought it
was great well I'm not surprised what
what did you say yeah it was awesome
dude
Superman action has never been so
freakin exhilarating I mean Amy Adams is
a perfect Lois Lane she's the best Lois
Lane ever apologies to Margot Kidder god
rest her soul she's still alive God can
still rest her soul
even if she's still alive or knows that
woman has earned a rest I'm not really
prepared for you to like a movie this
much you know like any movies well
that's not true yes it is I like lots of
movies
dude what's not to like all right
I mean Christopher Nolan was obviously a
steadying influence on Zack Snyder
Russell Crowe was boned to play jor-el I
mean damn and if that's not enough I
have three words for you kneel before
Zod Michael Shannon owns in this movie I
share a lot of these opinions and I am
definitely definitely not okay with that
like that is really troubling if you
really need to talk to somebody about
the movie who disagrees with you and
talk to the other you he hates
everything no he loves everything but
he's like the opposite of you do we're
talking about a guy that gave a standing
ovation during the credits of good day
to die hard what a piece of yeah movie
it's just terrible
no I'm talking about the guy what a
piece of B is for liking that movie you
know I'm pretty sure if you polled the
audience they would say that you're a
bigger piece I'm positive of that
actually whatever do you want to sing my
Superman song with me or not no no I do
not I don't do I mean you have to do me
a song you lost a bet remember no I
don't remember because you roofied me
and then when I woke up you said that I
lost a bet I had to sing a song with you
that is what happened that I even have
it on tape here comes
what is he even doing here isn't this
like a you and me thing you lost a bet
how many bets did I lose while I was
counting dude don't make me hurt you I
will kill you man
don't threaten me I mean I do have the
powers of Superman don't have the powers
of Superman if anyone has the powers of
Superman it's me right I have I can
prove it how proof okay yeah